hi I'm Eric run Houser community editor
at Atlas obscura and I'm here to show
you the greatest statue in Budapest
[Music]
discovering little-known public statues
is one of the great unsung wonders of
travel and the greatest public statue in
the world for my money is the bronze
Colombo in Budapest Budapest is a city
of statues you have the iconic little
princess sitting by the Danube the
policeman statue that is said to grant
good luck with a belly rub like some
kind of authoritarian Buddha or the
anonymous notary of King Bela also known
as master P wandering the city streets
it can seem like there's a new statue or
monument popping up every few feet now
leaving a side discussion of the
Troublesome politics of modern-day
Hungary after over a century of
political turmoil having been variously
occupied and influenced by other
cultures from the Austrians to the
Soviets preserving native Hungarian
culture is an important part of the
city's character figures both major and
minor have been captured in bronze and
locations across the city immortalizing
literary figures sports stars and Ronald
Reagan all in celebration of their
various Hungarian connections in the
spirit of this wide-reaching
appreciation for all things the Magyar
Republic can call its own the Colombo
Statute was born for those who aren't
familiar with Colombo well shame on you
lieutenant Columbo was the main
character in a series of TV movies and
later a series that aired between 1971
and 2003 played by American actor Peter
Falk Columbo was a cigar-chomping
salt-of-the-earth detective who looked
like he'd never laid hands on an iron to
say he was rumpled would be very correct
an archetypical wiseass gumshoe Columbo
was a vintage television treasure
without which we never would have had
shows like Castle bones house and
probably a bunch of other one word
detective shoes
the actor Falk who died in 2011 was
rumored to have been related to 19th
century Hungarian writer and political
figure mix of bulk while Peter Falk did
have some concrete Hungarian heritage
his familial connection to mix of Falk
seems to have been mostly coincidence
despite this connection never having
been exactly proven the possibility was
enough the statue of Peter Falk Columbo
was erected on the budapest street named
after misha funk as part of general
civic improvements in the area in 2014
they even added Colombo's pet dog whose
name was dog because who doesn't love a
dog Budapest Columbo statue might not be
the most sober bronze monument in the
city or the most secret or the most
popular
but it stands out as a singular example
of the fascinating and wonderful
oddities our global culture can inspire
generations of strife and political
upheaval leading to a need for cultural
appreciation so strong that it burst a
monument to an increasingly obscure
television character from halfway across
the world you don't have to be Columbo
to no that's a monument worth
investigating
hey thanks again for watching be sure to
subscribe to our channel for more videos
just like this one and possibly even
better go watch head down to the
comments and tell us what television
character do you think should be
immortalized in bronze